an intense filming experience and the
future of the wall crawler in question
Tom Holland is done with Hollywood for a
while here's why for several years now
Tom Holland has been one of the most
recognizable stars in Hollywood thanks
to his charismatic portrayal of
Spider-Man during his Marvel Cinematic
Universe tenure he's also taken on roles
in films such as cherry and charted and
more most recently he starred in Akiva
goldsman and Todd Graf's psychological
Thriller series The crowded room for
Apple TV plus a creative Endeavor that
has seemingly led to Holland taking an
extended break from acting the series
focuses on a troubled young man named
Dany played by Holland who ends up in
police custody following a shooting in
New York City's Rockefeller Center in
1979. as the story progresses the
investigators get an informative yet
harrowing glimpse into dany's psyche and
personal life shedding light on why he
committed such an act speaking with
extra Holland shared that in the wake of
the crowded room he plans to take some
well-deserved time off and I'm now
taking a year off and you know that is
is a result of how difficult this show
was later in the interview Holland
expresses his excitement to see the
crowded room in its entirety and hopes
that his hard work and the efforts of
everyone else involved with the show
weren't in vain at face value the
crowded room looks like an undeniable
home run with a strong cast and a story
that brings together the best of the
crime and Thriller genres how could the
limited series possibly fail evidently
for the vast majority of critics the
project doesn't quite meet the mark the
crowded room is sitting at a rotten 8
score on Rotten Tomatoes on June 8th the
day before its release with numerous
negative assessments to accompany this
score a reviewer for why now wrote It's
genuinely a joy to see Holland play
against his usual type but the crowded
room proves to be a disappointingly
middling uneven series colliders Chase
Hutchinson made a point to highlight the
show's unnecessarily sluggish Pace while
Nick Shaker of The Daily Beast notes how
Oddities that the crowded room gives up
its big mystery right at the start only
to pretend it hasn't for the remainder
of the Season as sir Bob Strauss of the
San Francisco Chronicle may use the show
to bring up a fascinating point that
speaks to Holland's wider Hollywood run
writing the young English actor has
struggled to find a dramatic project
equal to his charismatic Talent she
figured I was lucky have you ever been
lucky
no naturally the prospect of Tom Holland
taking some time away from film and
television after the crowded room will
lead to speculation regarding his MCU
future after all Spider-Man remains his
biggest role to date and fans are eager
to know when they'll see him done the
red and blue suit at the cinema again
work on Spider-Man 4 has stopped for the
time being due to the writer's Guild of
America's strike but even when
production kicks up again what does
Holland's Spidey future look like to
shed some light on his feelings toward
the MCU and the Spider-Man role Poland
recently shared with the Yahoo
entertainment so he can go either way
with it all at this point should we find
a way to tell his story and do justice
to him we will do so but if we can't
find a way to do that and if we can't
find a way to compete with the third one
then you know he'll swing off into the
sunset it seems that the future of
Holland's Spider-Man is in the hands of
the creative team behind the character
and a skilled writer's Tass was making
his films a reality
[Music]